than
we're all good on that
thank you uh if you want to come by
door all right on my
way little bottle of
alol
[Music]
hi Hi how are you
good
sure yeah I I was just uh I was out and
uh and I wanted to to park and E my
pizza and understand this looks
suspicious I've never met you before on
truck where is the it's up front oh okay
and it's relatively fresh okay so you
got to see my concern I smell alcohol
coming out of the car
so um officer Duncan you come over
here
I just I I took a and we find it strange
that you end up here
out of all places to decide to take a
rester or do
whatever did you happen to check cameras
yet or no I have not okay he said he's
only been
here
um and and I'm I'm trying to I can go do
that now if you want or we can hold off
no we could hold off on that right now
um do you have anywhere you need to be
um I I want to be in
displays um I want to get a a rental
today a rental yeah a rental um from the
Herz dealer okay did your truck going in
the shop or something or what no that's
how how I'll uh make money is Uber
okay all right very well all right well
based on the facts everything in
totality of circumstances all right I'm
going to ask you to step out and do some
Fieldy tests for me
okay have you ever done these before no
all right come on over here
sure it is all right so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going
to it's all right go ahead he kind of in
charge of the school right no but I know
him okay I do too
iuse do you expect when you end up in
the school park I I was just sitting
here
I do you expect to Happ nothing I didn't
expect anything to happen leave somebody
sleeping in a school parking lot with a
school full of kids so they School
administrator so that's why they're out
here okay okay um all right so do you
have any issues with your eyes no no do
you wear contacts no you normally wear
glasses no okay so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to put my
finger in front of your face and I'm
make a series of passes back and forth
all right so when I begin you're going
to stare at my tip of my finger all
right with your eyes and your eyes only
your head's going to remain facing
forward do you understand no would say
that again okay so I'm going to put my
finger right here okay look at my finger
yes you're going to follow the tip of my
finger with your eyes and your eyes only
okay does that make sense yes all right
there's going to be a series of passes
I'm going to go back and forth just
continue staring at the tip of my finger
understood all right very good
yes
what say that I got okay so I'm going to
put my finger right here okay look at my
finger yeah you're going to follow the
tip of my finger with your eyes in your
eyes on okay does that make sense yes
all right a series of passes I'm going
to go back and forth continue staring my
understood all right very
[Music]
yes
e
[Music]
okay
take a couple
BLS one more time on going go up all
right
all
right next one's going to be called the
walk and turn test you have any issu
with your legs no no all right goad pass
the first
one oh it's not really
pass it's it's a totality ofces all
right y
so I'm going to explain the directions
all right yeah we're going to pretend
there's an imagin actually you want to
use one of these lines or you want to
use an imaginary line um I don't
know makes me more likely to pass one of
these lines okay
gotcha go ahead and look at
me I'm going explain the directions to
you I'm explain the directions I want
you to place your left foot on the line
and your right foot in front of your
left foot touching Heel To Toe
keep your hands at your sides and remain
in this position until I tell you to
begin when I tell you to begin you're
going to take nine heel the toe steps
down the line turn around using a series
of small steps and take nine Heel To Toe
steps back I'm going to demonstrate
before you begin like this one all I do
two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 on nine all step your
front
planted and begin again 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 as you're taking your steps count them
out loud and remember to keep your hands
at your side if you have any questions
no let get back in that starting
position left foot on the line right
foot in front of
it one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 San coming
youring all right back over
here all
right this last test I'm going to ask
you just stand with the feet together
with your hands to your
sides okay when I tell you to be again
you're going to pick up either foot
whatever foot you feel like you balance
better on lifting the other one up
approximately 6 in with your toe pointed
to the sky don't
start while staring at your toe I want
you to count 1,1 1,2 13 1,4 1,5 1006
continue to count until I tell you to
stop if you put your foot down for any
reason just pick it up and continue
counting make sense yes
hold on I didn't tell
you12
20089 10 11 12 13
1 2 3 4 5
6 hang out with my for thank
you
this this is
awesome I was just chilling I was just
listening to the radio eating pizza and
and I got it's school time buddy what do
you want me to tell
you this what happen to anybody else
nothing this would happen to anybody
else that was in the lot during school
that's not supposed to be here
okay all right last thing I going ask
you to do is blow into some my pvt here
prob breath test
why
well you weren't
drinking all right why did I do the
whole field sobriety if you were going
to have me it's an option I give
everybody
option yes you don't have to blow in
this if you don't want to but if you
want to prove your innocence then you
can blow
in so it's up to you I'm not going to
sit here and force you and tell you
everything's going to be humy
Dory and to put things in perspective
this is an admissible in court all right
this is just so I get an idea
of
right so what you going to do you're
going to act like this in Ballo take a
deep breath in and just continue to blow
out until they tell you to stop that
make
[Music]
sense you are currently according to
this yeah it is all
right okay where time here uh do you
know what the legal limit is it is all
right so unfortunately for you at this
point you are under arrest for
awesome
[Music]
um good news for you is um I won't there
yet God damn it don't go back in the car
I'm not going to all right I'm doing you
a courtesy of this and not throwing in
Cuts right now please all right hang out
and chat with my
partner
rest just relax your hands just relax
your
hands I know you've been searched
already 102 but I've been I'm
transporting you so I got to search you
again okay
okay traffic traffic for
102 that's affirmative when you get a
chance can you check your
voicemail
okay go ahead hold
on is there anything else in your truck
that you
need I don't think
so okay
proba coins y just making sure man
gotcha we're paranoid yeah it's okay I
can put it back in his pocket may put in
the
big sorry gloves will make it
easier
just pull your hands back a little bit
for
[Applause]
me
okay we're going to go around to the
left side of the car or right side as
we're looking at
it oh
whoops yeah passenger
[Applause]
side you say we're 83 yep uh yeah okay
thank you sir I'll as soon as I can
okay
you need to help getting out no
okay right up the
ramp when you go through this door
you're going to make a right turn and
put your F on the on a black Footprints
okay okay all
right there you go so now this is going
to be more of a thorough a little more
of a thorough search okay sure you have
anything on you I have absolutely
nothing on me good to go just wanted to
be sure sure let me get the
gloves get towed off the property great
white's Towing has it um we'll provide
you the information on how to retrieve
your vehicle there's a 12-hour hold on
it so you can't pick it up for 12
hours okay all right sure um aside from
that uh there was empty Fireball
containers in your vehicle all right so
I also wrote you a citation for open
Transportation open alcohol thanks and
then the last thing was uh officer
Duncan called me in the school wants you
trespass from the location so you cannot
be at Crystal Lake South for any
reason if they see you there or see you
on video or something they could have
you arrested
trespassing oh okay all right so just
don't go back there um before I leave in
case I don't see you do you have any
questions for
me um no what's that last part I can't
go back to cryst L sou correct okay for
any